hello everybody my name is markiplier
and the cursed forest is back that intro
might have been a little bit too
energetic but anyway we're back with the
curse forest and my foot is so goddamn
asleep it hurts so bad
pins and needles in my right foot anyway
but as a professional gamer I must
persevere and do this blithering
darkness why is it suddenly dark it was
light and cheerful over there anyway
there's been the worst intro to any game
I've ever played good god is that dark I
cannot see anything
why do I always start these episodes on
such bad parts or good parts uh-oh
there's a light there it's just not on I
keep seeing things fall in front of my
face but it's actually just like leaves
and branches that are whipping by also
gently' am I supposed to I supposedly as
always I think my heart's full poppin
here cuz the saloons happened
okay you get louder okay
maybe that was an inclination I thought
I saw a branching path up to the left
but me being in it I decided that
continuing forward was the best strategy
always forward let's try that again
shall we
[Laughter]
I like this part this part is fun on a
barn okay
anyway see so there's gonna be plenty of
warning before I actually do get
devoured from my balls to my face just
one big line but at least they give me
warning okay I didn't see anything that
time okay so know that okay that wasn't
a branching path life that was just like
a log so what am I supposed to do wait a
minute oh I see something over there hey
is that it there's something on the left
there oh come on
I said it's right there it's pulsing
what is it doing behind that Bush I
think maybe okay okay I see you guys see
that - it's pulsing on the left there I
can't believe that word okay
okay oh okay oh good more branching
paths eeny Meeny I've always gotten left
so I'm gonna just stick to that all
right it doesn't let me astray yet
except for all those times that it led
me astray no actually now that I'm
thinking about it every time I've gone
left first it's been correct I think
left is best says uncle markiplier good
for me what is this a bridge
do I gotta cross a bridge are you not
gonna let me across the bridge I have a
feeling it's not gonna let me across the
bridge
oh that time you didn't kill me ah
that's dub that's the fuzzy of you don't
have enough eNOS okay so all that thing
I said about the left being best I
totally meant left was breast not left
was best of course breast is best unless
you're a thigh man I'm talking about
chicken what are you talking about
anyway let me just shut up with my inane
ramblings I'm trying to think here okay
I really wish there was a sprint button
but I'm just hoping that I don't have to
go through the forest to darkness and
death again of course it's all as a
forest of darkness of death but that
particular part was more darkness II and
a lot more death II namely oh there we
go I see a red glow oh I do just having
the fits so can I get it oh that's not a
bone that's one of those stones again
wait a minute that text is slightly red
should I should I pick it up every day
there's been red dokie sorry I don't
even okay I keep seeing these plants is
so much detail even the little itty
bitty plants move the grass moves
everything moves 150 frames per second
I've had games on the unity engine with
like a stumping up
I've had games on the unity engine with
like a stump and a brick in my computer
lag this is beautiful what was that what
is that that glowy glue wasn't there
before you can't tell me it was because
it was it that wasn't there before hang
on let me we take a look at this
something's what was that that a dead
animal that's a stick I was distracted
by a glowy stick maybe there was this a
graphical thing that one or maybe I'm
losing my mind
maybe uncle Varro is going a little
crazy okay so I've got the bones that
I'm collecting and else I need to
collect stones but I don't know how many
stones I need to collect I'm assuming
that this is all for some demonic ritual
of sorts so if I was going to guess
there's gonna be five stones because
then I'm it can make a pentagram out of
that see there it is again that's a
thing but I guess it's not really a
thing okay it looks like a thing I'm
gonna go back for it though oh come on
how many branching paths are there good
lordy Lou this game is much more
involved than I thought it was
exceptional work for an indie game by
the way and a free indie game
nonetheless I would have gladly paid
like five ten bucks for this game oh
okay
okay but I mean I guess the CryEngine is
for non-commercial use unlike the Unreal
development kit or something like that I
don't think you can monetize this one
without probably paying some huge
licensing fees or whatnot because it is
like a top of line engine you could
probably make movies out of the
CryEngine look better than some of the
crap I saw I just saw John trans recent
video on foodfight that wonderful
amazing animated film if they can make
something like that but I'm sure that
you can make something on a game engine
in well I give it a try oh good a glowy
glue surrounded by blackness
okay oh oh every bad feeling
[Music]
okay I did not like that one bit I
didn't like it one bit
nobody better send me no email saying
that oh I missed something I don't care
I'm not going in that place ever again
God okay you shut up four lakhs Tom
thine tits god of thunder seriously I
would have gladly paid ten bucks is that
a lady is that a lady screaming
seriously I would have gladly paid ten
bucks for this this is an amazing game
this is incredible work seriously
top-notch
oh okay there we go there we go okay I
wasn't sure what I was looking at
there's so much Foley it's going on that
I can't quite piece it all together my
brain can't hit oh good that's probably
the other part of the leg that I need oh
it's just oh I don't need to go to the
bathroom anymore I've already crapped my
pants
I'm not wearing oh what the
whoa hey whoa hey whoa wait hey some go
and funky up there okay
okay why do I speak it go slower indoors
anything that I need or no oh another
stone good good should I look up I don't
think I need to look up
No what do they do
why was I supposed to do something sir
Oh
ah what was I supposed to do Wow could
I've done all right bring it on you
[ __ ] left no you didn't see nothing
Ford hit by it oh that's not a good sign
okay
and no happen and no happen you shut
your mouth you see all the times I was
saying no I said no close to my oh hi
what it on a side shimmy fast enough
oh you so beautiful okay
okay doors squeak open let me try to
close door because no way in hell am i
trusting that what am I supposed to do
what do you want from the Great and
Powerful markiplier maybe I got a creepy
crawl my way out I gotta do something
[Music]
okay so here's the moment of truth I'm
just gonna stay to the left and not look
don't look
oh he's right there but oh oh the
scenery
painting is delightful I can't
appreciate ear I more time okay so what
I think is happening is when I get past
a certain threshold no matter what the
camera spins looks at him and then he
tries to get you but there's a chance to
run away so that's what I'm gonna try to
do anyway I can't seem to no see does
that it turns me around okay so as soon
as it flips me around I need to turn
backwards bolt out of there done finally
ten tries oh all right I'm done finally
I'm out of the house but I think of all
that time that's frustrating that's
really not the best way to go about that
unfortunately I died a lot a lot a lot
of times in there and I saw the monster
a lot kind of overexposed it to me I'm
really sad that that's what happened and
it wasn't exactly fair I got caught on
the doorway trying to go in when I was
in there it wasn't clear what was
happening it wasn't clear well though I
was supposed to do I took me a few tries
to even realize why I was dying and it's
fun the camera round on me I had to back
up I didn't even realize what I was
doing by the time it was happening that
was beside the point that was like 50%
me taking a while to get it but also 50%
back
been done way better anyway I'm all that
time so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
Oh
[Music]